bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés ce soir
nous allons évoquer avec nos invités un
domaine en pleine crise l'agriculture
prix trop bas manque de reconnaissance
endettement important le monde agricole
est en difficulté les mouvements de
colère se multiplient maintenant depuis
des semaines et notamment au salon de
l'agriculture qui se tient en ce moment
à paris alors cette situation concerne
tel l'ile-de-france et les yvelines
particulièrement
quels sont les enjeux pour les
agriculteurs de demain les politiques
sont-ils à la hauteur pour répondre à
toutes ces questions sur ce plateau jean
marc gaillard producteurs et
agriculteurs bio des yvelines pierre bot
également agriculteurs et adhérents du
syndicat professionnel des jeunes
agriculteurs ile de france ouest et
enfin bruno myle yens conseiller
régional ile de france vous apprenez
vous appartenez sujet man group du
centre et des démocrates à la région ile
de france et vous êtes membre de la
commission ruralité et agriculture
bonsoir à vous trois alors avant de vous
donner la parole à chacun faisons un
rapide topo sur l'agriculture en ile de
france dans la région c'est environ cinq
mille exploitations
un chiffre qui ne cesse de baisser
depuis maintenant 40 ans près de 600
mille hectares de terres agricoles la
production est très largement céréalière
en tout 49 % du territoire est dédié à
l'agriculture et dans les yvelines
on est à 952 exploitation 89 milles
hectares et 39 % du territoire
ma première question est simple
l'agriculture francilienne est elle en
crise aujourd'hui comme ça peut être le
cas dans le grand ouest pierre bot pour
commencer à titre personnel vous qui
êtes agriculteur comment vous vivez
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous ressemblez à
ce tableau un peu triste qu'on dresse
aujourd'hui des agriculteurs en pleine
crise la tête sous l'eau au bord du
gouffre alors sur mon activité de base
sur lequel je me suis installé il ya
huit ans effectivement on est dans
crise assez importante on a le prix des
céréales qui est sur des niveaux
anormalement bas donc on est en dessous
de nos coûts de production
on ne peut pas continuer comme ça
décemment pendant quelques années alors
j'ai la chance avec ma compagne on a
démarré il ya six ans une
diversification en fruits et légumes
maraîchage en circuit court
on a investi massivement les bonnes
années là dedans avec aussi des soutiens
à l'investissement la modernisation au
niveau régional et ça nous a permis de
ça nous permet nous nous les gages est
revenu sur cette partie là actuellement
quoi et certains de vos collègues
peut-être ou confrères qu'en est-il vous
discutez j'imagine avec eux notamment au
sein du syndicat professionnel
clairement économiquement que ce soit
dans les filières alors vous l'avez dit
l'île de france est majoritairement
céréalière dans la filière des céréales
actuellement les prix ne sont pas
rémunérateur et même pour les personnes
n'ayant pas trop mal vendu sur
pendant la moisson on arrive à clôturer
à zéro ou à quelques milliers d'euros de
revenus annuels
bien loin d'un smic comme on pourra
espérer pour un jeune qui s'installe et
dans le monde de l'élevage c'est pas
forcément mieux même si les quelques
éleveurs qui restent en ile de france se
sont beaucoup orienté sur la vente
directe et ça leur permet de dégager du
revenu mais on reviendra presse sur les
difficultés de la vente directe aussi
s'est il ya aussi des difficultés dans
ce domaine
ouais on évoquera ce sujet jean marc
gaillard vous vous êtes dans le bio vous
êtes maraîchers quel est votre point de
vue à vous sur la situation générale
alors on va dire de l'agriculture en
général puis de vous qui est dans le nom
plus particulièrement je suis pas un
arrêt chez mes producteurs de fruits
producteurs de fruits excusé petit
détail mais je trouve que moi
personnellement le modèle agricole
aujourd'hui il est en crise il est en
crise depuis un certain moment
modèle qui est à revoir au niveau de
l'aspect technique de ces surfaces
modèle à revoir également au niveau
économique
voilà qu'est ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
fait effectivement pour que l'engrais
l'agriculteur puisse s'en sortir
lui-même avec une certaine
indépendance donc voilà il faut la
situation qui qui est qui et celle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui dans l'ouest de
la france s'applique également à l'île
de france sait pas s'il n'y a pas une
bulle il ya peut-être une bulle parce
qu'effectivement vous avez un potentiel
de clients en ile de france qui est
énorme
ceci dit en province beaucoup
d'agriculteurs je parle en bio
évidemment ce comment dirais-je arrive à
trouver ses clients par le biais des
amap système amap que l'on connaît et
donc il ya toujours matière à faire
c'est pas parce qu'on habite en province
que comment dirais-je en bio on va mal
vivre son métier bruno myle yens vous
avez été élu au mois de décembre c'est
tout neuf pour vous est ce que vous avez
pu déjà dressé au sein de la commission
ruralité agriculture à un premier bilan
écoutez et en premier constat peut-être
on commence façon la crise agricole est
partout et les nationales horse avec
nous on va s'attacher à un petit peu à
l'île de france mais elle est vraiment
nationale elle touche de plein fouet
tous les agriculteurs les témoignages
que vous avez eu la juge juste avant -10
bien que voilà ça touche toutes les
filières et ce qui nous manque je pense
c'est une vision à plus long terme de ce
qu'on veut faire de l'agriculture en
france on le voit sur le sur l'île de
france 2 les dix essais à 60% des
céréales
peut-être il faut penser à faire un
petit peu de diversification on sait que
le bios a particulièrement bien marché
l'année dernière je crois parce que le
chiffre d'affaires était en hausse
globalement bien sûr de 8 et 10% dont il
ya quand même des secteurs qui sont qui
sont porteurs on a tous souvent été
considéré comme le jeu par le niveau de
l'europe comme le grenier des pays
émergents à qui on allait exporter tout
ça peut-être qu'il faut qu'on les aide à
faire de l'agriculture et nous
préoccuper de ce qui se passe aussi sur
nos territoires on a dérégulé la
dérégulation elle y est pour beaucoup
la voix de la france aujourd'hui je suis
désolé de le dire je veux pas faire de
polémique mais à l'europe c'est niet
quand on a misé de l'agriculture qui
n'assiste qu'à 60% des commissions
c'est pas suffisant parce qu'on a besoin
de ça la dérégulation je pense que ça a
été une catastrophe alors maintenant on
nous dira la régulation la pac
les subventions tout ça c'est de
l'assistanat
moi je suis pas un fervent partisan de
l'assistanat mais il faut dire que ça à
aider l'agriculture mais avec cet
assistanat on aurait dû avoir un projet
si ce n'est européen au moins nationale
mais je pense que ça peut aussi se
régler au niveau de l'europe un projet à
long terme qu'est ce qu'on veut faire à
la fin de cette agriculture maintenant
qu'il faut qu'on la rentre aussi dans le
problème climatique on connaît la coop
21 vient de s'arrêter on le sait on a un
vrai problème de climatologie ça va
avoir des répercussions importantes sur
leurs sur leurs activités
il va falloir qu'on se pose les bonnes
questions je suis également président de
natureparif il ya une étude qui est
sorti il ya pas longtemps
qui nous dit que si en matière de
biodiversité ont fait rien d'ici à 2030
on se retrouvera dans une situation
quasi irréversible 2030 c'est demain
parce que quand on annonce ces dates là
les gens voient ça très très loin et en
fait c'est pas très loin quand on dit
qu'il faut inverser le réchauffement
climatique d'ici à 2100 2100 - mes
petits-enfants ils ont à peine 90 ans en
2100 donc pour moi c'est actuelle c'est
pas un truc complètement aberrant et
donc il ya tout ça je pense qu'à un
moment ou un autre il faut que tous les
partenaires mais sincèrement comme il ya
eu un grenelle de l'environnement ce
serait pas mal qu'il ya un grenelle de
l'agriculture et que tout le monde se
mette autour de la table on a entendu
les revendications elles sont légitimes
après il faut vraiment bossé avec les
agriculteurs faut bosser avec des
acteurs du terrain pierre vote
on entend beaucoup de problèmes
aujourd'hui des prix trop faible un
endettement trop élevé
manque de reconnaissance une crise
morale aussi du monde agricole des
règles trop nombreuses en france trop
tatillonne
c'est vraiment tout ça le mâle de
l'agriculture aujourd'hui ou alors il ya
peut-être un point sur lequel il faut
plus insisté un point qui est essentiel
qu'il faut régler aujourd'hui plus qu'un
autre moi je pense que oui effectivement
il ya réellement une crise morale on
nous montre souvent du doigt des
producteurs qui ont fait depuis des
années des efforts dans toutes les
filières
certes il ya peut-être des choses encore
amélioré mais cette crise morale
elle est aussi dire au mal être parce
qu'il ya eu des crises économiques
multiples dans l'agriculture mais
conjugué à cette crise morale c'est
d'autant plus dur pour les agriculteurs
à pau c'est ça le plus important
aujourd'hui le plus grave c'est cette
crise morale au delà de ce qu'on peut
c'est pas le plus important mais je
crois je pense que ça s'additionne et e
et puis par rapport à cette crise
souvent on entend dans les médias voilà
ça c'est peut-être la solution cette
voie là c'est peut-être la solution
il n'y a pas une solution il ya des
solutions je pense que voilà quand on
prend l'exemple des circuits courts nous
dans la région ile de france il ya du
débouché on parlait de production de
céréales 60% des céréales en ile de
france si on prend purement les
statistiques
l'île de france est tout juste
autosuffisante en blé par exemple parce
que si on prend la production de blé
francilienne et la consommation qui se
fait en face ils le français toujours
autosuffisante l'ile-de-france est
déficitaire de production agricole de
toute façon 12 millions de consommateurs
quand même donc on assez pas 5000
agriculteurs qui produiront pour 12
millions de consommateurs jean marc
gaillard / sur cette vision là les
problèmes aujourd'hui qui touche le
monde agricole
qu'est-ce qu'il faut régler selon vous
en premier en urgence il faut
apparemment il ya des choses beaucoup de
choses c'est énorme si vous voulez
permettre aux agriculteurs de vivre
décemment de son métier sans voilà en
étant complètement aussi au saut du lit
autosuffisant et sans subvention ni quoi
que ce soit bah c'est pas demain quand
quand va-t-on revoir ce modèle riscle
encore une fois je vous le dis est ce
que comment parler de modèle agricole
vous vous pensez à quoi par exemple à
tva dès à des fermes trop trop familiale
peut être n'ont pas trop familial mais
défaits 1 peut-être parfois un peu trop
grande qui finissent par prendre des
dimensions qui trompe qui sont
absolument phénoménale temps nous dit
souvent l' inverse on dit qu'enfin
justement là encore ce modèle familial
contrairement à l'allemagne il alterne
avec des métiers d'antan quand ça reste
quand ça reste tout à fait humain n'y a
pas de souci mais aujourd'hui quand on
voit ces grosses entreprises qui
s'installent un peu à droite à gauche
qui deviennent effectivement énorme
qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'humain là dedans
qu'est ce qu'on recherche finalement est
ce qu'on recherche quelque chose de vain
un bien-être animal et humain
ou est ce qu'on recherche une espèce de
l'agriculture mécanique mécanisée
entièrement de 0 à 100% et voilà et
c'est une malbouffe dit faux faut
revenir à la base pour venir une base
agriculteurs faudrait revenir à une base
d'agriculture sans pesticides si
possible aujourd'hui les pouvoirs
publics apportent des solutions baisse
des charges soutien au crédit est de
pour de l'investissement dans du
matériel
est-ce que c'est avec ce type de mesure
que l'on répond aujourd'hui à la crise
de l'agriculture bonne au millième fois
je pense que pour parler que de la
baisse des charges on va être honnête je
pense qu'il ya pas un agriculteur qui
est dupe
ça a effectivement ça c'est un emplâtre
sur une jambe de bois s'est passé soit
et puis là ça va les soulager un an deux
ans trois ans mais on n'aura rien résolu
pendant ce temps là il faut il faut tout
de suite qu'on amorce le dialogue tout
de suite qu'on une vision si si on n'a
pas ça demain on va continuer année
après année à faire du court terme faire
du court termisme c'est ce qu'on fait à
peu près depuis je ne sais pas une
trentaine d'années
justement quelle est la vision de la
région ile de france aujourd'hui pour
l'agriculture par exemple eh bien vous
avez déjà quelques pistes
bah c'est un peu tôt parce qu'on
s'installe mais déjà on a une
vice-présidence à la ruralité à
l'agriculture qui est présidée par un
marché donc ça c'est une première déjà
il va y avoir une conférence on va
mettre en place une conférence régionale
où tout le monde va se mettre autour de
la table on va écouter les gens c'est un
petit peu le principe
qu'a insufflé valérie pécresse à la fois
pour les agriculteurs mais à la fois
aussi pour le développement et pour
l'emploi je pense que si on ne prend pas
la vie des gens qui sont spécialistes du
domaine qu'on veut traiter parce qu'il
est malade
et bien c'est un peu compliqué c'est pas
nous il faut qu'on les aide il faut
qu'on comprenne il faut qu'on arrive à
avoir un poids non seulement au niveau
la région ile-de-france mais portait
aussi ce message là au niveau du
ministère parce que la région ile de
france et comme la région capitale c'est
la première région de france on a quand
même un poids il faut s'appuyer sur nous
à les porter le message au ministère de
l'agriculture au gouvernement mais aussi
à les porter le message à l'europe je
pense que l'europe aujourd'hui elle est
totalement absente et nous sommes
totalement absents des décisions que
prendront et ce n'est pas normal
l'europe n'a pas le droit de laisser
tomber les agriculteurs alors que c'est
aujourd'hui vous qui êtes agriculteur
pierre bot vous attendez plus de qui des
politiques des politiques français de
l'europe type qui peut vous aider
aujourd'hui
alors moi je dois je pense que je
rejoins tout à fait ce que dit jean marc
sur le fait que idéalement tout
agriculteur rêverait de vivre de la
vente de sa production et sans
subvention et sans subsides quel qu'il
soit néanmoins la réalité fait que les
prix du marché aujourd'hui ne le
permettent pas et effectivement c'est
pas des baisses de charges contre eux
quand je vous jure elle conjoncturelle
qui vont faire d'une réforme
structurelle de l'agriculture alors
après la responsabilité elle est quand
même avant tout avant tout dans le
consommateur quand même qui choisit ou
pas d'acheter on va quand même
en trente ans il ya eu une
transformation dans le budget des
ménages c'est-à-dire que à une époque
l'alimentation c'était le budget
principal d'un ménage maintenant ça
devient la variable d'ajustement c'est à
dire que passent en priorité les loisirs
des vacances l'automobile et après
l'alimentaire est en fait le seul
consommateur mais tu es un petit peu
plus sur l'alimentaire on sortirait de
cette problématique
voilà alors ça c'est de la première qui
est la première marque mais c'est pas
que le consommateur dans le supermarché
ça va être le consommateur aussi au
travers des restaurations collectives
car l enjeu avec la région avec les le
département avec avec toutes les
entreprises je prends pour exemple
aujourd'hui ce matin à 9 heures
il ya le bureau national des jeunes
agriculteurs qui a été au siège de
france télévisions ce matin faire un
dans les cantines voir les origines des
produits les fruits et légumes étaient
majoritairement français mais la viande
était d'origine irlandaise ou de
république tchèque
voilà alors après on nous fait un cash
investigations qui venait aussi qui
contribuent à la crise morale sur
l'agriculture mais mais voilà on
s'applique pas c'est propre le racé les
propres règles dans dans dans les
restaurants d'entreprises dans les
restaurants collectifs
donc il l est aussi là la solution je
pense la solution c'est le seul
consommateur et c'est aussi peut-être
favoriser les circuits courts c'est à
dire marc gaillard ans est forcément
mais c'est aussi deux voilà de zapper
certaines certains intermédiaires on les
connaît tous ouais ça qu on rappelle ce
que ccc vous basse évidemment un match
au couteau c'est une vente à la ferme
c'est un système de distribution d'amap
c'est
des livraisons à droite à gauche
pourquoi pas c'est voilà face à des
solutions viables ça ou ça peut vous
permettre de vous aider est ce qu'on
peut vivre concrètement quand on est
agriculteur uniquement avec des circuits
faut savoir ce qu'on veut
pierre bot j'ai eu l'expérience
notamment alors avec les consommateurs
ça se passe plutôt bien c'est ce que je
disais au départ on a la chance de se
diversifier dans le maraîchage et ça
nous permet d'assurer un revenu
aujourd'hui mais par contre on a été
abordé par des restaurants collectifs
qui détient on mettrait bien du local
d'accord nous pourquoi pas on est
capable de faire un petit peu plus de
produire pour vous on va faire un
contrat de culture qu'elle quel prix
vous nous proposez abat sur le marché de
gros rungis savent autant j bon on va
pas commencer à discuter comme ça parce
que c'est pas du tout de la bonne
méthode c'est combien moi ça me coûte
combien je suis capable de vous le à
quel prix je suis capable de vous le
vendre décemment de migros et après vous
ça vous intéresse ou ça vous intéresse
pas mais on sortira pas du système si on
reste sur des sur des référencements de
marchés nationaux aujourd'hui le il faut
plus qu'il faut plus que la base soit
effectivement les prix de gros parce
qu'évidemment tous les détaillants se
réfère à ses plis tôt aujourd'hui on
zappe quelqu'un qui est passe pour
expérience personnelle un qui passe
effectivement d'une vente à 90% gros à
une vente à 90% en direct en deux trois
ans je puis vous dire que la loi c'est
vous qui la fait donc attentivement vous
êtes plus tributaire de ses systèmes
d'offre et de demande si vous qu'il ait
terminé le prix pour en vivre
c'est facile à mettre en place et ses
circuits courts excusez moi de me
pencher sur gt en place vous même à au
sein de vos exploitations le gip
écossais c'est facile à mettre en place
by admin on août ces agriculteurs qui
veut peut alors ça c'est limite
effectivement qui veut peut tout le
monde peut faire des circuits courts
après qu'il ya certaines productions qui
sont quand même plus compliqué quand on
prend le monde de l'élevage on obligé de
passer par une filière d'abattage
classique pour les gros bovins dans la
région il faut qu'ils aillent dans les
départements limitrophes mort de la
région pour faire abattre et ramener
leur viande donc ce à des coûts c'est
aussi du temps pour les éleveurs parce
qu'ils emmènent eux-mêmes leur leurs
animaux ils reviennent et chercher
quelques jours plus tard donc le temps
sur la route le temps donc sur un
progrès culteurs qui fait déjà 60 70
heures par semaine
effectivement s'occuper de tout ça et
faire le commerce en plus c'est encore
des heures en plus pour pouvoir se
dégager un revenu
donc il ya aussi cette question là quand
même à se poser parce que le circuit
court c'est un débouché mais c'est aussi
du travail en plus et des besoins de
main d'oeuvre en plus bruno myle yens je
dirais que là où la région pour être
vertueuse sur les circuits courts c'est
notamment sous la restauration
collective des écoles des collèges et
des lycées lycées c'est votre compétence
un décès c'est notre compétence non voit
que en seine et marne jean jacques
barbot a déjà fait cela avec les
collèges
donc on peut reprendre cet exemple là
alors ça ça ça sous-entend aussi que les
parents d'élèves comprennent qu'ils vont
payer un tout petit peu plus cher le
repas de leurs bambins mais que leurs
bambins vont manger des choses de
qualité
donc là on en revient aux consommateurs
enfin même si c'est légal envoie
confiance des consommateurs on est enfin
je pense que tout le monde est à peu
près d'accord pour dire que depuis 40
ans on nous emmène vers la malbouffe de
manière dramatique et que je suis désolé
mais moi je suis dans une élue d'une
petite commune s'appelle jumeaux ville
mon voisin du dessus que j'adore à son
potager quand ils me donnent une ou deux
tomates je les mange à la croque au sel
parce qu'elles ont un goût de tomates
voilà c'est tout quand j'achète une
tomate ont supermarché je suis désolé de
le dire n'a pas le goût de tomates dont
il ya un moment où il va falloir éduquer
aussi le palais et ça passe aussi par
les enfants
là la région peut être très vertueux en
dehors des aides qu'elle va amener bien
évidemment aux agriculteurs il avait
signé d'ailleurs un contrat avec la
région les jeunes agriculteurs le jour
de l'ouverture de du salon de
l'agriculture donc tout ça on va le
faire mais il ya toute une forme
d'éducation à faire il faut revenir à
quelque chose de normal de st moi je
pense à ces éleveurs par exemple j'ai vu
alors je ne sais pas si c'est le cas en
ile de france parce qu'il ya pas
beaucoup d'éleveurs mais un éleveur qui
ne veut même plus manger sa propre
viande parce qu'on la considère de pas
bonne qualité moi je suis désolé ça me
pose problème
pierre bot vous vois sourire ça ça vous
arrive et on les séries les quelques
éleveurs qu'on a dans la région encore
ils sont un peu victimes de leur succès
c'est à dire que ils ont six mois de
commandes d' avance donc il a mangé
votre problème
il y en a certains se sont devenus des
des hôtels il ya certaines fermes
d'élevage sont devenus des hôtels à
animaux il rentre il mange du soja qu'on
importe
et puis après ils vont à l'abattoir et
que fait l'agriculteur l'annoncé en fin
l'éleveur est fait pas grand chose
finalement
il sait pas grand chose mais c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment la
conception qu'on pouvait avoir de
l'agriculture ou de l'élevage et encore
ne serait-ce que 40 ans on devait à une
époque quand la politique agricole
commune a été mise en place on devait à
la base sanctuary zay les l'agriculture
c'était c'était parce que c'est de là
que vient notre nourriture c'est de là
que c'est grâce à ça qu'on convient
qu'on mange ça pas été fait on a mis ça
au profit d'un truc très productive
istres et capitalistique qui a
fonctionné pendant un temps le fort
heureusement et c'est un on voit
qu'aujourd'hui ce modèle là est en train
de s'essouffler
il faut penser à autre chose mais c'est
là c'est là où je dis qu'il faut qu'on
se mette autour de la table
moi j'ai pas de solution on va vous
amener des aides on a des plateformes
comme je le disais pour qu'on va mettre
en place pour la relation que de
restauration collective ça va aider
effectivement les agriculteurs de france
à sortir un tout petit peu la tête de
l'eau mais après il faut vraiment une
vraie prise de conscience et pas
seulement des politiques des
agriculteurs et des consommateurs
alors à un modèle qu'on cesse de se
répondre c'est le modèle bio c'est celui
que vous vous pratiquez vous aujourd'hui
2 % de la surface agricole de l'île de
france et féfé du biome est-ce que c'est
celle à venir selon vous est ce que
c'est la solution miracle que l'on peut
attendre un peu comme les simples
courses et sandero la délétion mais
selon sa solution sans doute la solution
miracle
j'espère pour l'humain simplement pour
la terre oui je l'espère parce que
parce qu'il est temps aujourd'hui de de
promouvoir cette agriculture qui
qui ne fera que du bien pour pour
l'humanité entière donc voilà je reste
campé sur ses positions là qui sont
évidemment très très content des
positions de conviction vous ayez par
conviction que vous vous êtes mis au bio
louis xi a ou a toujours été le cas non
puisque
j'étais conventionnelle jusqu'en 2009 et
donc apprécié les rencontres de
personnes les gens qui nous font prendre
conscience d'un certain nombre de choses
de de voir que ce que l'on manipulé bien
c'est extrêmement dangereux
c'est sur les poisons que l'on applique
sur terre qu'on applique sur soi-même et
pour les clients donc abandonné on se
dit voilà il est temps d'arrêter de
raisonner aujourd'hui ça marche les gens
viennent vers vous naturellement
reviennent le manoir du le jour on est
patient conventionnelle évidemment la
boutique existait déjà et donc
effectivement sens où les personnes ne
sont pas revenus ils sont revenus un peu
plus tard d'autres personnes nouvelles
sont arrivées
forcément vous avez savoir qu en ile de
france la part de marché en bio c'est à
peu près 30% et ça augmente alors que
c'est en fin d'après midi je peux me
tromper
2 % de la surface agricole utile j'avais
un peu plus mauvais ça reste très minime
pierre demeure votre alors ton point de
vue moi je reviens sur ce que je disais
il ya pas pour moi ya pas une solution
il ya des solutions pour sortir de cette
première ticket agricole après le bio
effectivement c'est une des pistes
moi j'ai quelqu'un dans ma famille qui
s'est mis à faire du légumes de plein
champ bio
il s'est retrouvé aussi en surproduction
oger pas là le marché n'est toujours pas
gérer sur cette question là il ya quand
même une question à se poser aussi sur
les termes des outils de régulation qui
peut y avoir parce qu'on peut aussi
avoir massivement des conversions qui
peuvent entraîner des surproductions
encore une fois après le modèle bio
c'est un modèle il ya des modèles
intermédiaires aussi c'est pas blanc ou
noir on n'est pas une société binaire où
tout est blanc tout est noir jean-marc
ne fait pas que du bio non plus donc en
fait
faut pas faux pas je n'applique est ici
d'un vraiment mais c'est pas cp on peut
on peut faire les deux modèles
intermédiaires vous dit vous disiez
l'agriculture raisonnée par exemple il
ya ta d'un panel très large dans ce
domaine là et après la principale
problématique quand même c'est dans la
région pour le développement du bio faut
avant tout développer l'élevage et je
pense que faut raisonner interfilières
parce que on pour faire des productions
végétales en bio on a besoin d'eux
d'amendement organique de fumier sans
élevage on n'a pas su me et là alors
voilà parler d'un modèle de circuits
courts on va importer du fumier de
bretagne pour pouvoir cultiver en bio ou
de belgique
j'ai un peu du mal à concevoir ça comme
un système et après on parle aux gens de
consommer du local quoi donc moi je
préfère je suis plus du bio pourquoi pas
moi j'ai voilà j'ai une amie qui ça qui
s'installe en bio là en élevage c'est
une une belle une belle initiative
son père fait des grandes cultures bio à
côté son frère va reprendre
l'exploitation donc des céréales bio
donc effectivement voilà ces vertueux
après le modèle il n'est pas il n'est
pas unique
je voudrais juste vous entendre sur une
dernière question avant de conclure
cette émission est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous êtes optimiste pour le monde
agricole ou est-ce que vous pouvez
l'être et notamment qu'est ce que vous
diriez à des jeunes qui pourraient se
lancer dans la filière alors je
m'adresse d'abord à vous des jeunes
peut-être qu'ils sont en lycée agricole
aujourd'hui ce que vous leur dites
allez-y foncez
croyez en ce qu sans doute que l'avenir
en ce qui me concerne c'est forcément le
domaine de la bio
oui c'est un domaine qui est
économiquement porteur on le sait c'est
un domaine un domaine qui est
humainement évidemment important donc
voilà je crois que c'est sans doute une
question de bon sens aujourd'hui elles
veulent beaucoup de l'agriculteur civray
s'installe
moi personnellement d'avoir reçu des
gens qui sont en conversion
professionnels des gens qui postent d'un
métier un autre quart bottes emilie
bruno millièmes pour conclure il faut
oublier le système actuel quand on est
jeune aujourd'hui agriculteurs et et se
projeter sur deux un nouveau modèle non
je pense que mais les jeunes lecteurs
ont pas attendu la crise pour en arriver
là
on essaie tous de diversifier nos
sources de revenus
donc que ce soit par la diversification
des productions la création d'un atelier
supplémentaire donc un peu à un petit
élevage en vendus en circuit court
diversification au maraîchage en
arboriculture ou autre autre production
soit en valorisant une partie des serres
elle aussi par le biais d'un fournil
transformer en pain etc
il ya quand même pas mal de gens il ya
25 ans il ya des amis qui sont lancés à
faire de la bière aujourd'hui ils font
une bière extraordinaire voilà cessé il
ya plein de production de
diversification qui se sont faits sur
les exploitations déjà depuis des années
qui permettent d'assurer les sources de
revenus et après quelques uns bas n'ont
pas trouvé leur voie de diversification
sur la ferme donc ont une double
activité à côté il ya eu beaucoup de
diversification aussi dans le dans la
pension de chevaux dans la région parce
qu'une forte demande aussi des les
consommateurs et là on revient sur
d'élevage éventuellement des sources de
matières organiques pour d'avoir des
productions plus respectueuse de
l'environnement et des amendements de
matière organique dans les sols bruno
myle yens en tant qu'homme politique
qu'est ce que vous dites à ces jeunes
qu'il faut peut-être donné d'abord j'ai
envie de l'ain 01
j'ai envie de leur dire que si c'est
leur passion faut qu'ils y aillent ça
c'est la première des choses parce qu'on
a rien de pire que de faire un métier
qui nous passionne pas bon ça c'est la
première chose derrière
je pense qu'effectivement on va dire
c'est encore une parole de politique
mais je pense que là ya réellement
urgence à repenser ce qu'on veut demain
faire des terres agricoles de l'élevage
est tous à la biochimie progresse il
faut travailler avec c'est avec ces gens
là parce que nos terres sinon on va les
appauvrir on va même fait avoir des
terres qui vont être catastrophiques
mans infertiles au bout d'un moment donc
on est rentré dans un processus où on va
revenir de toute façon vers quelque
chose je pas forcément employé le terme
écologique mais disons de plus naturel
par rapport à ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
maintenant on a quand même utilisé à
foison beaucoup de pesticides etc
il faut revenir à quelque chose de plus
raisonnée pierre a parlé de
diversification rien à la
diversification de l'élevage où il en
faut il faut qu'on aura introduisent en
ile de france notamment
il faut faire revivre tout tout ce
vivier et toutes ses productions qui
existait avant et qui ont disparu et
pour ça il faut vraiment un projet il
faut qu avec les syndicats des
agriculteurs tous les syndicats les
agriculteurs avec les politiques qui se
veulent se prendre part à ce projet on
se mette autour de la table et ont
redéfini ce qu'on veut et il ya urgence
je vous dis il faut qu'on le sache
rapidement pour qu'en 2030 ce soit
effectif ça sera la conclusion de cette
émission merci
vous 3 d'avoir participé à ce débat
c'est la fin de ce sept huit sociétés
une émission que vous pouvez retrouver
en replay sur tv fil 78 points comme
bonne soirée à tous